where do you live i live in austin
that's simple
okay so we gotta get like a little bit
deeper into this okay so like latin
around them awesome
what music do you listen to
okay so
i listened to
like all kinds of music which is fun um
like recently i've been kind of into
like meditation and like
yeah so it's been like it's it's
like sort of like long-form songs that
are like 10 minutes long 12 minutes long
and it's like very simple words so like
just over and over
what's your favorite mantra song
it's called
do you have it memorized
thank you give it up for chris and
they're talking chrissy music
we did he's definitely from austin he
listens to 12-minute songs about mantras
which side of the east
side do you live on the eastern side
he's coming to gentrify your
neighborhood
they hear 12-minute mantra songs you
know your breath is about to go up 500
bucks i know
it's actually quite lucrative what do
you manifest
uh so abundance obviously
what do you think about positive
thinking
oh wow it's it's just positive thinking
does oh it only goes so far right and so
if you're gonna go like one step past
positive thinking it's manifestation
right so if you're gonna like manifest a
particular thought you have to like
think about it and then you also have to
like let it go so you're not attached to
that point and that's exactly so it's
like a non-attached experience like
every thought in the world yeah
what is it you're falling for this
[Music]
what do you think about white people
that's a good question
that's a very interesting question um
it's a hate love relationship
comes first
it's a love-hate relationship
you gotta thank white people
[Music]
did you look at chris and thank him for
something white people did
creativity
thank you chris for your creativity i
love you
guys
other people's cultures yeah cool making
it your personality i'm sorry
[Music]
yoga all those years ago oh that's a
good question i was doing a lot of
running and running was challenging and
so like yoga was like the way to go um
but thank you and then what kept me in
it over time was having
uh basically
not an ability to deal with like the
emotions that were coming up and so like
that then you know with meditation
when you're running well i said i don't
know the running was like a great
experience
but this was like later in time in life
yeah yeah so you can transition
exactly transcendence into
the spiritual enlightenment do you have
a job
yes
thank you the opening statement
doesn't work i don't know
so you were running around
i was running around town lane before
yes like a pool like training for a half
marathon found the yoke and then yoga
was there and that was like a nice way
to like make my knees not hurt how long
have you been running from your
sexuality oh my god i'm running very
like towards my sexuality at this point
not running towards it latin rap
aficionado
whereas my grandma calls it
rat and laughs
[Music]
into it yeah so i know a lot of
mexican music and then latin rap is just
right there all the time what makes land
rap better than rap
it's cool
and
it has more expression and it's not so
derogatory towards women in a way
that's cool i can never understand it
but i assume they're talking about drugs
it's more dance you can kind of think
do you do any of it could you do a
little no i could not do it wait so do
you know that
yes
it's from like early 2000s but they were
in yeah so it was like
like have you heard of this band bro
[Music]
chris can you do your impression of
latin rap what you think latin rap
sounds like
because we know you're dude the man that
you just claimed yeah so it's it's been
a long time and all the bunch of music
is like coming through my head right now
thank you thank you i appreciate it uh
no i cannot
at the moment but let me think about it
for a second
is there another style of music you'd
like to hear
americans
can we get a freestyle
american rapper all right so
um
monsters because nobody wants to see
marshall the more they want shitty on
chopped liver well if you want shitty
this is what i'll give you a little bit
of wheat mixed with some hot liquor
candles
by the doctor when i'm not cooperating
we're on a rock at the table while
you're operating hey you waited too long
to stop complaining come back i'm on the
ragging ovulating i know that you got a
job as cheney but your husband's hot
problems complicated so the fcc won't
[Applause]
[Music]
m
[Music]
he's cool
that was that was awesome did you uh did
you grow up with a lot of eminem in your
life no that was the one song
so largely like my like one song from
eminem yeah it was one song
you should have
chosen to lose
a good one too we like the range a
little higher uh bombs over baghdad too
was a good one
against cass for sure so chris uh what
do you think about uh latinas
hi mommy
[Music]
yeah wow yeah what happened there man it
was great and there was a lot of love
so it was good
until it was not
yeah there was lots of fire
did somebody set you on fire uh she
wanted to at some point for sure
[Music]
so uh what are you usually talking about
on dates brizzy
um their day-to-day life routine oh
interesting yeah what's your name
do you like no no i want to hear why you
have a tarot card on here yeah i do yeah
so there's something for you chris
please stick to the subject that's okay
i like
okay
so
i
wake up half the days i take my children
to school and so i've got two kids i've
got a nine and a half year old and seven
year old
which is like absolutely incredible
because for the last five years i feel
like i've been driving them into central
austin which is 40 miles a round trip
not cool so the walking to school is
fantastic and then okay thanks for
asking that question
you're asking one question he goes on
for thirty minutes you gotta yeah i
tried to talk about her
he goes to school he walks around what
what do you do why do you have a
tara
you guys are great at dates
uh what about you chris you're killing
it you have two kids
you were dating for us singles
the reason why i asked about
his day is because i feel like you
really get to know someone how they
start their morning so you can tell yeah
i learned he has kids
that's really cool
pretty good to know how long have you
been uh in a relationship with your baby
mama with my children yeah with the
their baby mama that was 2005
and then that ended in 2021
wow yeah
20 21 yeah the end of 2021
is the old man is she the mexican trying
to say
you know no fertile they are i would
love to see that uh
suit affecting parent child
relationships yeah
brizzy he's a man with children does
that
take him off the market or are you more
interested
[Music]
she's letting you live here
this is a successful day so far yeah i
don't
want someone with already kids
can you love her
so can you elaborate
[Music]
i i am still pretty young so having to
deal with someone else's kid seems like
a big burden to me
yeah [ __ ] your kids chris
no one wants to take care of them
i love kids but i would like my own kids
not look after someone's part my
partner's other kids that would make me
feel very jealous what do you think
about that rachel
i don't know there's a lot of
assumptions
she set that you know boundary at first
yeah
you know having a plan b or abortion in
the next couple weeks right
yeah later abortion
but 20 you can hire her maybe i was just
thinking like and you're in north austin
so that works right now
i'm glad we came to this like mutual
mobile relationship i would love to look
after your kids but i don't think you
could ever go on a date that's that's
cool but you're going to do that
man
this is a date yeah
it's a damage we met on the stage you're
currently
in charge of his children your parents
legal guardian did you come here with
someone chris i did she's over there
yes
cool did you come here with taylor do
you like his kids oh taylor
[Music]
so you're like do you want to go on a
date and watch me date other people yeah
that was a little strange but like we're
here
are you signed up for the show
very specifically yeah oh you're in the
lgbtq bucket
are you signed up for the show uh no no
i just like you you just like to watch
have you guys ever been into
have you ever been to an orgy
excuse
[Music]
we
[Music]
oh yeah like eventually like life
partner
yeah that's nice i prefer the strategy
to lock them up and
[ __ ] around
it's working so far that's good so uh
brizzy uh
how old are you i'm 22. wow where did
you uh did you go to uta output over
there no so i moved from seattle
that explains the tattoos yeah
and the pink hair pink area
how long have you been in antifa uh
she was about to answer
nothing
uh so are you vaccinated yes yes of
course
over at harborview or
yeah
some others evergreen these are seattle
hospitals that was impressive yeah i'm
from seattle
yeah where why don't we ditch chris and
go on
today but uh yeah that's cool you're
from seattle chris is from austin yep
born and raised
[Music]
it's been bathed in the waters of barton
springs i was literally having a
conversation today that's where i go
[Music]
yeah
for sure likes to bring his kids to
watch titties with it yeah what's uh
what's your favorite thing to do with
your children besides walking to school
uh currently it is watching uh the last
airbender avatar the last airbender
which is great
[Music]
whole philosophy um life yeah and
they're they're half indians so we get a
little bit of the engine there as well
native american or no from india the
subcontinent
that's cool
so you like to date around for different
brown people i guess
sometimes sure
have you ever gone middle eastern
uh that's a good question
i don't think so
you haven't had some of that tzatziki
sauce oh no so i'm half greek
so there is like yeah so if we're
talking about like greek being in the
middle east maybe but yeah no yeah it's
not it's it's not it's still in europe
sure you're great so you like [ __ ]
little children okay
taylor uh-huh
[Music]
hello
making an austin baby
so uh what did you think about his
children were you like oh i want to have
fun or were you like
let's uh let's make some tick tocks out
of these let's monetize these children
at least
we need you to meet these kids
she just wants the kids on her face not
actual it's got dark
man
welcome to the show
it's nice to be here chris is a very
self-aware gentleman it's all that yoga
he's done thank you this is very much in
the present
what's your favorite thing about yoga
what's your favorite position you could
show us
uh this one right here it is the
meditative sitting in the chair the
cubicle marker cubicle worker for sure
famous
seated yoga pose that's what we do every
monday for like meditation it's great
you sit in a chair every monday yes
every monday through friday
oh you have a office job yeah it's a
nice job so the favorite meditation i
like um if i put this down for a second
eating an indian woman's [ __ ]
that was still 20 21.
i don't want to say
whoa
that's
called the
what's that while you're going back and
forth on that thank you you say
you're 22. you have no issues but do you
think you could learn you could do that
sometime at the
in your classroom
i would definitely do that
what uh
[Applause]
is brizzy your real name or is that your
latin rap name
my latin browning so you signed up in
the pseudonym yeah so can you sing
around for us no
it's my nickname
so why
yeah
that's awesome
how did you get into nannying i love
kids and i love working with kids it's
not chris's kids
not my partner's kids no
yeah
and i like seeing kids develop through
each stage so yeah this was the best
thing for me yeah
[Music]
what do you like to make them do as you
nanny them are you like
i'm actually a pretty strict nanny so i
have a schedule for them and time they
have to eat and they have to be able to
take their nap can you make them clean
no i'm not cleaning no just have fun
that was racist just because he's
mexican doesn't mean i was because i
want my house clean when i come home
if you could help me with that that
would be amazing that your children go
through this
so you have a schedule for the kids yes
if you were to look after chris's kids
as a nanny what would what do you think
that they would do maybe a little yoga
started out
so they're just
seven nine and seven seven seven nine
seven so yeah this is a good time for
sports and going out and socializing
with other kids their
and
i would probably get them involved in
clubs and other friends so they can have
that social
aspect in their life
maybe some after school studying like
reading
math um but yeah it's also important to
have fun so i don't get them to have fun
yeah not a lot of support
so yeah
good job not a lot of housework and
that's what you're looking for yeah
with children
ever since the 1920s
maybe just clean their room
yeah but that's it that sounds very nice
yeah that's awesome you sign them up for
clubs hopefully socializing
having their own individual
personalities
yeah
get them vaccinated behind his back
[ __ ] nailed it
she's from seattle yeah that's true yeah
and he has a crystal around his neck
so chris what uh what got you with the
indian girl yoga oh no statistics class
oh my god
second most racist thing you said
just because she's indian
we're both engineers so we're nice yeah
and we were like you know she was in the
front of class and i went down and sat
down next to her
that was in 2005
yeah it was a different time back it was
a different time you could talk to
indians
i mean i went to georgia tech so like
oh my god
i went to georgia tech really yeah i
graduated 2011. of course i'm a little
young seven years
damn they're four years older than me
what was going through the same school
mechanical engineering
what the classroom
so klaus yeah it was in it was in the
big lecture hall and those clouds yeah
yeah yeah dude you were on point with
these yeah references you people don't
appreciate it because it's not funny but
like the fact that you like failed
seattle and georgia tech like very good
yeah this is a manifestation of my
nightmares right now
from school those are
little figments
anyways anyways if you guys were to now
i feel like you see me better this is
great yeah he went to georgia tech
school with 30 women and he snagged an
indian brawn yes
it's hard to do it's difficult
i don't even speak the language
so uh was she a foreign exchange student
or she was born in virginia uh okay boy
okay
acclimatized to the white [ __ ]
brizzy how was your college career
it was fun
did you meet any indians
yeah
indians and asians back in seattle oh
right yeah you went to uw no shoreline
shoreline nice
and you uh what uh what was the closest
you got to
having two children
not close at all
oh my god abortion is legal there yes
they're heathens yeah unlike here yeah
so why don't you uh get the little
little pill
you you wanted to have children with the
indian girl no not at all
uh well i really wanted children it
seemed like the right thing to do at the
time it was great yeah you do you're
good yeah that's something
no guy wants children oh i want children
like wanted unless they do now i have
the two when i'm very upset
but like they're great have you ever
done any bisexual activities uh i rubbed
a guy's chest here
that was nice sounds like a frat party
yeah no this was like a
house party like it was fun
awesome
and you're from seattle and you're
shaking right over there
what do you guys think you guys if you
were to go on a second date which won't
happen because you already blew your
vote into something
yeah twice what where where do you think
you'd go maybe to barnes springs
uh where would you watch this
yeah it would clearly be at my house
yeah his house or
if we could go to a museum with his kids
that would be fun i do not want to take
my kids to their dates
just to be clear this is a work day yeah
it's a work day yeah well okay i would
get paid you would see that's the next
day is i would be paying for sure
it's a hot date
give it up for chris and brizzy
[Applause]
we're gonna roll into the
lgbtqia plus bucket we actually got some
takers this time
because since pride week in austin
we got cats
hopefully they're both lesbians
[Applause]
the community here an open-minded
progressive show
and not to be canceled because we're on
your side okay give it up for ken
do we start now i don't like the smile
on your face i do that's right you're so
super scared i'm not scared
now we're here
i like your haircut
oh my gosh if this isn't a date we
should be best friends what's a very
queer woman they're going to be like
anyway you're so beautiful
[Music]
what do you do for work i am the
designer
okay
i'm an influencer manager
it means i make a lot less money than
the people that i manage i see yeah and
i mean like what's the range of the
folks that you're managing they're like
oh like
multi-million
follower types so you're like
the one who's like wrangling the like
kardashians yes exactly
um do you play video games
no but you know what i want to get a ps5
for the cat game
for straight yeah yes i do get it i'm on
a wait list for
[Applause]
talking about video games on a date this
is why i wish i was a lesbian
a big no-no
uh what do you think about this
beautiful
couple i think
i like their chemistry
i'll come sit at your table okay
i'm
[Music]
well you know i'm the closest to a
lesbian
so
i'm uh giving a good case for why
women don't date men anymore yeah um
going strong
so uh what do you do you do design i do
design
could you like
make me like cool clothes
or is it a different kind of design i
guess i thought fashion but maybe you
meant something else oh that's sweet
when you think that but um probably
maybe it's like a hobby i have
but what kind of design do you get i do
like so i'm mostly a consultant and like
the consulting
is for design so i'm like doing
consulting for people who are doing
products
does that make sense she steals rich
people's money
[Music]
you steal from kardashians
no not that level but so what's the
craziest thing you've had to do on
social media for someone like
photoshop someone's
hairy
elbows most of my stuff has been like
behind the scenes kind of like
production being on set pretty sometimes
things uh but if you're asking like my
craziest story was being outed on the
set of one of my uh
influencers she was like do you like
boys or girls
and i was just like
i suspect that's not a question you're
allowed to ask people anymore and she's
like it's okay my kid's gay
wow yeah that means she's not homophobic
that's exactly right and i was like oh
like you're an ally so
it's actually why chris married an
indian girl yeah so he can't be accused
of racism my kids are
weird
but uh yeah
so they were like trying to find out if
you were like
not straight yeah you know she wanted to
tell me that if i was the only child i
should marry the oldest kid of three if
i was straight um so she had a really
useless fun fact that she just wanted to
tell me that involved my sexuality being
a part of the
equation so if you're a middle child
you should [ __ ] someone who's the oldest
child yeah
interesting strategy
celia what uh what where are you that's
cat
[Music]
i was like
chat yeah
i got it right this time
uh
how long have you been getting
it's been a minute
so uh yeah are you uh are you like where
are you in the order of children are you
the oldest or the middle oh i thought
you meant like in the order of being gay
like
you found the gay gene
the oldest
so you should
you should date someone in the middle
apparently according to this influencer
i'm in only but
i i think that's too much is uh yeah i'm
the only choice in my family lineup so
okay okay two one for one that works
you guys doing anything fun for
pride week
i went to the parade yesterday
yeah you went to track brunch this
morning
was it the big booty breath brunch it
was not it was vixen's
yeah they're actually talking to each
other it's weird
i think they like each other
any of you do any of you guys have
children yeah i heard my dudes
[Music]
so uh
what uh what do you think about children
do you think that they're the future or
get rid of them not their future
okay i mean
they're creative
um
[Music]
yeah they have some positive qualities
different ways to kill themselves
that's true
rachel uh would you ever have children i
have two oh
what happened with the children are they
are they are they doing good right now
we hope so
they're in my trouble
but they're fine are you indian by
chance not yet
just sign up for a couple more yoga
classes i'm going to manifest
got to think about it don't let it
go it was our thoughts yeah you nailed
it
forever don't stop thinking that's the
lesson from the show
never stop thinking yoga with chris yeah
and crystals and kids
so do you guys believe in horoscopes
that's like a big queer woman thing i
know
it's my it's my nightmare to be asked
about it on dating apps because i know a
lot about my sign and all
[Music]
well you know what they call it in asia
right
oh
is also what we call our lunch
oh
okay
i'm asian
they have lunch that's what we want to
do we eat weird things
i think the colorado virus came out of
nowhere um but
[Music]
uh
cecilia yeah what uh what do you like
about austin
is it good for the lgbtqia community
um
sometimes
you have your whole street here fourth
street
but it's not a neighborhood it's a
street then they're gonna and they're
gonna destroy
those clubs in like a year
to put in a luxury like salad and steak
place so the straight people can go hang
out there more than they already did but
they're going to keep the gay stripes in
the street at least to be like oh yeah
they were here once i think austin's
really cool to be
a gay man but not very cool to be a
queer woman
personally i feel like there's a lot of
when i go out and i like hit on someone
it's like either oh you're not gay you
don't look into me and then a lot of
like oh i'm straight i'm here with my
friends and you're like okay
i'm just gonna go kill myself but it's
fine i'm glad you're here
yes very difficult
[Music]
but you guys are on a date how do you
feel about the date so far i'm liking it
no i think we should go out again
where would you go where would we go
what kind of things do you like to do i
guess that would be my question
um
okay i like museums i like good
restaurants i like my cat
i have two kids
do you like dinosaurs
do you know what i had
done
okay
that's fair
so do you like dinosaurs are you a dino
[ __ ]
oh yeah that's a good one i asked you
what to say when you was
[Music]
teaching them how to speak
incorrectly
so what what did you ask about dinosaurs
i have a t-rex skull tattoo uh on my
left shoulder and have you ruined the
field museum in chicago
okay well we can go together and then i
can show you where my tattoo is in the
t-rex exhibit there
that's a sexy excuse me man put your
shirt on i know
this isn't forced i don't want to wear
it anymore exactly i'll wear a
tastefully revealing crop top so you can
see it
the thought the elegance we love it
thank you so that's how you do it yeah
i'm learning a lot from you guys
how old are you
[Music]
i'm just
a citizen of the world
i travel all
over see different things get that stamp
on the passport
anyways i'm sounding like chris right
now and i hate myself
[Music]
i just manifest whatever
dreams behind yeah man a different
countries what do you like about the
model you went it's not even the real
you know there's a real you can go to
the u.n yeah but like modeling mine is
like
they also do historical things so
that was at one time the nervousness
it was when you're in school yeah
which country were you
uh i was colombia
are you colombian i'm not
i'm half filipino
colombia of asia
indeed
yeah
drugs
yeah
we do a lot of like extra you know
judicial killings
hell yeah
so what do you do you you pretend you're
colombia you go up to [ __ ] chile slap
him around or yeah like wrestling it's
kind of like verbal slapping around so
it's like yeah
uh so you get people and you're just
like you're
doing it wrong with your water or
whatever
get over here we'll make it better come
be part of my committee
nice yeah it's a lot of good people
robert's rules
[Music]
i mean some people were like intense
about it they would bring like these big
binders full of like information
[Music]
so people brought binders they would
argue it was like debate clubs like yeah
like debate club but it was like like
larping
yeah amazing plus larping plus like
international awesome yeah
so what's one awesome citizen arrest
all these papers that i'm reading from
i'm not an attorney but i will simpson
arrest yes
just like take them out of the
room all right you're done this is on
page five take it down yeah stop
resisting
you're gonna get the colombian you're
gonna get this poke in your ass cocaine
in your nostrils
uh celia what is your favorite country
if you were to be in the modern u.n
would you be
would you represent a country
can i think like any country yeah
in the u.s
[Music]
there's a lot of good countries
which country are you
[Music]
okay my son
would be italy
and my speaking lesbian now
we need a
[Music]
why i don't know i just always like
googling pictures and been like estonia
is such an ugly pretty language okay if
you've ever wanted to learn like have
you ever wanted to learn like a language
that's not going to ever be useful to
you
right now
well you go to germany estonia it's like
who am i going to talk to can we not go
to estonia yeah we can
but we could
but we have to learn the language
okay wait so then did you have a rising
oh oh my rising italy and estonia right
italy
okay okay my third one
okay because my third would be
japan um because
i'm big into anime so that would be mine
i like that okay
she loves it there you go no
do you like uh
what is it
you like dinosaurs video games in japan
there you go that's and cats and cats
and influencers
you are pretty much the king queen of
japan you know that's they're pretty
autistic there
um so what you said it's not me yeah i
know
i'm seeing a lot of shifts tonight
rachel thanks for joining me check her
out on instagram
there's this pilot priest since we're
gonna just do the handle that was an
interesting handle
so uh yeah you you're like all over the
place nerd with nerd culture do you go
to comic-con and do you dress
[Music]
which one
so when i was growing up in high school
you could like before comic con was a
big thing you could like volunteer and
or like just take somebody's passes
[Music]
give me your password
hello
so uh celia you uh you're a pretty big
nerd
yeah you like video games yeah do you
twitch
um i've tried to i currently
but i find twitch deeply confusing you
said you'd never been to a con but you
worked for influencers who were the
biggest con of them all
it's not just a daily show social
commentary
so like what does that job uh
led you to have you ever been jet skiing
because you've been an influencer oh
i've never done anything cool because of
an influencer
no have you ever been influenced
by an influencer
um maybe like my new boss um he plays a
lot of video games so like i'll kind of
watch his streams and i'll be like that
looks cool uh if only i owned a ps5
i know exactly now i'm like get me on
the list
[Music]
have you ever been into video games
uh you know not a really long time like
everything was like
you know well maybe you could play
around with her controllers if you know
that
i want to choose
oh by that i mean your joystick
anyways
what do you think about this couple
rachel you think that they really think
they have a lie
yeah i'm excited to see where this was
so yeah please stream it on twitch yeah
put it up on instagram
yeah princess pilot priestess we'll tag
you
thank you
yeah thank you
yeah then we'll invite you to the
wedding in like two weeks yeah it sounds
like that's where it's going
i would like to be the flower girl
honest can be the ring bear okay
like i'll sort it out yeah we'll put
your like faces
you have your whole street you're
complaining
give it up for this beautiful lgbtqia
plus couple
[Applause]
a lot of dudes tonight
a lot of
40 dudes
uh we got james coming up
here he comes
[Music]
[Music]
anyone else want to come up and date
this guy
all right come on up here
[Music]
yes it is give it up for madison there's
stairs over there or you can do that
and
what is his name james james
madison
james madison hi madison what's the
minute of dating
someone else that's asian as well
[Music]
and go talk to each other like you're on
a date
what kind of base are you
taiwanese
wow i know so little about that please
inform me a little bit about that
yeah
i feel like it'd be rude if i didn't ask
uh we're the ones fighting china
for independence
so are we we are looking for
the us yeah
of china
exactly
[Music]
oh gosh oh do you want my like american
answer or do you want an honest answer
honestly
i'm white and i live in america but uh
ethnicity was i guess uh
in the american version of that i am
scottish and irish because i have red
hair and i can have been lying to you
but you have to believe me okay yeah i
believe anytime he believes her
believe all women give it up for
james and madison
madison you ask what kind of asian are
you oh yeah is that usually
not get a call to the police or
anyone call you karen or something
no i've never been called to karen
however
police do hate me
um for the most part because i am
they're small and hard to catch
no that's not even it i think i just i
make too much eye contact
so they hate that that seems to bother
them it humanizes it's like it's a no no
no no it's it's something that predators
do when they're trying to
creditors are you trying to eat me right
they're
let
other
now
i feel like a cop
[Music]
uh
james i mean
taiwan
so uh what did you think about this
white woman
she's cool
nice that's what most asians say about
me
yeah you're way cooler than you know
asians asians are
very docile quiet polite people and
well my attachment style is something so
i tend to attract them
nice
so
you know he said uh inform me
inform me about china
are you uh
are you sure that he's not a chinese spy
like
well i haven't seen him on tick tock so
i'm pretty sure
where's james why are you not on
tick-tock
do you have tick-tock on your phone
right now i don't damn you really are
taiwanese
that's taiwanese as [ __ ]
yeah what did you think about nancy
pelosi going over to your motherland
all right it's all right
nancy pelosi james approves
wait wait i didn't say that
i was saying her going to taiwan is all
right you sound like a rapper did you
are you from reborn in the us uh no i
was born in taiwan that's why you sound
like a rapper
yeah taiwanese famously known for the
rap
oh no
like non-native asians are famously
known for learning how to speak english
like by listening to the
black people that beth talked
about
okay unless we're talking about eminem
or like
i don't know what's
[Laughter]
in english
james what are your hobbies or interests
uh
i
read
i
ride a motorcycle
damn you're a bad asian
yeah to my mom yes
are you reading while riding a
motorcycle sometimes
you choose a very dangerous mode of
transportation yeah oh it's for fun not
really transportation okay
okay kawasaki like that's that's uh
they make pretty good motorcycles
japanese brand yeah
yeah i'm just saying that you can't say
you're a bad asian if you write a
motorcycle
well my mom does
my mom says that yeah
i would never disappoint my mother
you're a comedian yes you would
i am a comedian
yes you're a private jet i'm
appreciative
what do you do for a living
uh i'm a data analyst damn your parents
must be
very mediocre
like that is math
we love that
so what do you do you look at data you
analyze it
yes that's correct
and uh
what do you do with these numbers
uh
i make predictions
about what china's gonna
wait do you do you do you give
information to the last woman that's up
here who consults designers
because like that kind of seems like
just [ __ ] going down the line you
know
well the last one up here was a
consultant for designers and it
maybe it's just me but
like that just sounds like
one of the most
fun non-jobs i've ever heard you know
just
analyzing data it just you know it's got
friends
i could most likely analyze any kind of
video
damn this is an agent's flirt
have yeah um oh gosh i always hate this
question because i feel like i sound so
boring um i'm into like fisting and
painting and physically
[Music]
a lesbian bucket
where he went through that
[Music]
or painting or something
[Music]
are you fisting your paintings
well okay so yeah as a hobby because
like one of my other hobbies is i really
like convincing straight men that are
gay that they're gay and
uh also i really like convincing
straight women
basically i just like convincing
straight people that they're not
straight and fisting is one of like the
surest ways to do that because somebody
who has not been fisted yet if they can
do it successfully like it violates
their
understanding of their own identity so
much that they're like maybe i am gay i
don't know
don't tell your mom you met a woman
who's trying to fist you tonight these
american women are crazy
trying to fist our tiny little asian
bubbles
you might be
okay this is how it starts you might
so what is this
[Music]
well
it was just
like okay okay so
if
[Music]
i don't know someone was just like hey
like just let me fist you and i was like
no
and then i looked it up
you googled it i googled it analyze the
data i i analyzed the data
and i'm very competitive
i think that's really what it was is i
was like i don't have to be into this
but i've got to [ __ ] do it you know
and so i i was just like all right try
me and it was fantastic and turns out
i was bisexual the whole time
so
[Music]
james what's the craziest thing you've
done sexually
this is going on on youtube
[Music]
oh he's doing it right he's blowing
himself
i can tell you but i'd rather show you
just
once
[Applause]
that does not mean that you're not into
fisting
as an umbrella category
butt stuff fisting fits in there
you've not fisted or been tested
there's no no one making a fist around
you when you're you don't want to
elaborate on butts stuff uh no i don't
this girl loves talking about fisting
this guy
kate's talking about this
it's usually the other way around it's
usually the dudes that are all wanted i
feel rude jumping in but this is going
to bother me because i was raised to be
polite i don't know your name it's
rachel rachel thank you for asking no
you cannot miss her
please focus on the asian man this is
our beautiful guest
i really like magazines
[Music]
madison
yeah that's the thing what's your name
yeah the female's name yes the data is
in my brain
uh yeah for a living
data
data analysis and what do you do for a
living so you make money that way it's
not just a hobby right you've got that
what do you do
it's hobbyist i'm just like the fisting
plants
okay so this is really the most white
woman answer ever but what do i do for a
like for money or like what do i do yeah
yoga teacher
no i'm not a yo-yo it's a good question
to ask the question um so you know just
what's your career of choice
oh my career choice um elementary school
teacher what do i do for money stripper
wow those two things go together they
absolutely do
unfortunately yeah you ever missed your
first graders
oh sorry i actually said something wrong
um
no
i i have not which i shouldn't have to
say uh
um no i uh i i do like to bring a little
bit of like a like a sexual edge to the
classroom
[Music]
oh yeah
okay don't act like you didn't live i
thought i moved to seattle
yeah no because first graders there it's
no um i uh i these conservatives are
about
somehow i feel like you've changed the
most lives being an elementary school
teacher
but i
get paid like
three bucks every quarter-ish for for
that job so i went back to dancing
because i am very good at it and i can
make a livable wage doing so
yeah
you ever treat your
stroke yeah sure
well you ever treat your uh customers
like first graders or kindergarteners oh
absolutely absolutely i do you know like
back when i didn't want to say i was a
stripper if i was like in a setting i
couldn't say that i would just say that
i was a therapist or a babysitter and
anybody that's been to a strip club you
know exactly what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about okay like
very very vulnerable that that is you
know giving a lap dance to somebody
most of the time
like can you give a lap dance to james
right now sure why not i have to have
music i won't do it quietly
[Applause]
please change the song
absolutely this is royalty-free music is
all we can afford
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is too much data for this data
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell us your secrets
that was very interesting
i'm sure you're gonna analyze the data
afterwards all right this is where the
real power moves
do you mind grabbing my shoes for me yes
it's gonna fix you don't do it
there he goes the unfisted james from
taiwan
so where are you working
now he's interested
now he's asking the questions
i want to pay you money
across the street from one of the sports
stadiums so i mostly get a lot of
young men with their mom's allowance
coming in thinking that they're like
super hot you want to dance because
they're just super [ __ ] fun that's
where you teach kindergarten but where
do you uh
well seattle's really progressive so
because they're also you know trying to
like get ahead of the gentrification
they just bring the kindergartners
through the third grade classrooms to
the club and i get to you know go like
on and off like you know you switch
between the private rooms and the
buildings oh yeah that's how they do
that
i have the money school buses across
from that stadium you know where
she is see that's why like we really
look down on private schools in that
area because like that's really the only
thing we have
james do you have any questions for her
maybe in regards to her performance
how would you rate the performance from
one to ten
from one to four inches
that is far too generous please don't
see me i'd love to know how much money
we make
she's going to be visiting taiwan soon
so you don't live in austin no i'm i'm
traveling cities that have comedy scenes
to see where i want to move
[Music]
seattle my jokes do not go over well in
seattle
at all so
rather than your kindergarten teaching
but uh
james what uh what do you think about uh
madison maybe moving to austin is there
something that you could like convince
her to move here with into your paycheck
he's got to crunch numbers first
i cook
i cook what do you cook i want to know
what you cook i love i love asian food
which i know sounds super engineering
but like i pretty much exclusively love
asian
uh cuisine so like tell me
mostly chinese and japanese food
[Music]
can you tell me what a taiwanese dish is
i'm just like genuinely curious uh
freedom
[Applause]
[ __ ] communist
capital investments
free trade with the world
[Music]
[Music]
yeah like what like people come on you
add spices lemongrass thyme
mostly soy sauce
[Music]
some msg
yes a couple of
blocks of wasabi msg is [ __ ] awesome
if you go to like like like an asian
they essentially are asian costco's like
all the ethnic stores that like get set
up in things like warehouses whatever
you can buy bags of msg it is so
wonderful
i have one at my house i never used it
it's just there because it's hilarious
we actually snort msg
to get that asian below
and we're like interested in rachel's
bangs like your hair is amazing like
do you get kind of people at yourself
[Music]
okay i'm not trying to fist her but if i
did i'm very small
that's right i already did like three
times after the dance
winning for both of us
yeah
is this that you want to ask me
seriously who doesn't like
[Music]
there's still time you know there is
still time
never think that it's too late to change
your sexuality thank you straight all
right i'll remember that he's really
trying to piss you out
no it's a slow process convincing
someone that they're gay like
so what is your favorite part of uh
making someone gay
i don't make anybody gay you can't do
that you just
you you draw it out of
stick a finger in there and then slowly
make it bigger
no it's all about validation it's just
like accepting the little nuances about
them in conversation to the point where
like the next time somebody asks them
like what's your sexuality like it
always starts with them like pausing and
then they're like
i'm bisexual
and you act like you didn't know right
you just paid your homework
your mom's about to pick you
no that's fine that's uh that's great
you know
but uh rachel are you uh have you ever
thought about
fisting
[Music]
if you're like constipated or something
that would be called anal
oh you do it in the are you doing the vj
absolutely okay i'm learning a lot
this is a sex education for asians
advocate for anal fisting that's not
meant to stretch back down vaginas are
so impressive oh we're talking about
vaginas
oh we're talking about vaginas this
whole time
yeah
uh james yes what's the longest
relationship you've been in and not with
your mother yet goddamn mama's boy
uh
year and a half wow
was she taiwanese or she was wow how did
you guys meet um
we went to the same high school
and then when i moved here i found out
she was here
[Music]
[Music]
and it's not the ice skating website
that's
ringtone
so you better what no i seriously like
i'm so genuinely curious about this how
do you get an asian dude to like date
you as a white woman because like you
guys always end up marrying asian women
i've been trying to get an asian dude to
date me for years try [ __ ] them
horray lonely
okay
i didn't say i haven't done that before
i just mean like how do you how do you
get them to like
introduce you to their family you gotta
meet their mother and try not to fist
her
that's fair step one that was my first
mistake i guess
what usually what would happen if you
brought madison to your mother what
would she say
[Music]
if i was quiet what would she say if
you're quiet she'll like you
just don't tell her
yeah definitely
i i know a lot of chinese lettering does
that work well she like that yeah
cool
of course
so i'm making a good case but absolutely
i can do that
madison what would you do if you met
james's mother
bow
take your shoes off
uh
take your shoes off first
let's put chopsticks in your hair
like just [ __ ] like
like her [ __ ] hair into a bun and i
spent years learning how to do that
correctly and like i can't totally take
my shoes off i can do like a ninja bun
and shut the [ __ ] up and do some chinese
lettering
yeah
so you're making me want to join china
what do you think about south korea's
james what was that noise
you're jealous of our kpop that's what
it is i don't know
yeah south korea is my favorite country
i'm out of here better than north korea
taiwan what do you what do you think
about south korea huh
it's a cool place
thanks just you know a little bit below
taiwan
not in terms of gdp here
[Applause]
suicide
[Applause]
coming up
you don't want to go on any of your
names with a bucket
we're going to
see a medicine
where madison is going to
come up here again
do a lap dance in front of your
boyfriend
and we got caleb coming up
sammy is
a friend of that guy
from that table job and caleb is a
comedian
give it up for caleb and sammy
[Applause]
great to meet you
as well
are you from austin from salt lake city
actually where do you just live no way
i'm from salt lake city
i'm not there right now so i'm not sorry
really where are you
uh six and uh like uh 600 east
um no i was there uh two years ago so
yeah are you from utah
okay so you're a mormon
i can't buy you durian sorry
[Music]
but you're still born in utah
that's a rare person
oh we already have a lot of time
[Music]
well now you're just like 19. so really
really hearing all the different form
and stereotypes
so you're just visiting them
oh you do live here oh very cool
yeah
well
[Music]
give it up for caleb and sammy
two non-mormons living in utah
so uh what uh how do you like austin so
far
much better culture than utah
that's not hard to do yeah so very low
bar i'm coming from yeah this is new
york city compared to salt lake city
so caleb what uh
what did you think about sammy's uh utah
heritage i'm impressed that you don't
have a connection to the mormon church
it's like one in a million in utah
it's rare you guys are both wearing
rainbow shirts
jerseys like
very
yeah
for the concept of rainbows
yours is very uh you know a strong and
you know like uh
inclusive i guess or whatever and yours
is just like some random [ __ ] you found
in your closet that's exactly what you
did
what uh what made you wear that shirt
today did you know it was right i
actually didn't it was a total
coincidence i looked at it and i said
that one
well you're gonna get hit on a lot
tonight i'm gonna go out and see if you
missed it if i can get some numbers
sammy what did you uh think about caleb
on the one-minute date that you were on
[Music]
you're asian um asian so it's like sir
we got a lot of commonalities in that
respect dude a lot of people think i'm
ancient
no one thinks you're here
you said that to me with your eyes as
wide open as you can
[Music]
mockery
what did you think about this date
i thought they were
getting along really well and
i don't know
but
they were about to have sex or something
i felt it
like they were they're like
i'm not married
it was like really
i followed the orthodoxy
of the lds
okay i don't know what that means he's
saying a lot of speaking english
say he's asian
so sammy what was it like being asian in
utah
everyone knows
she's not white
did you ever run into a funny situation
where like people were like bowing to
you
getting their shoes off um no but
oftentimes in utah
[Music]
like where i'm really from often and i
would tell them
my family's from cambodia and they'll
often say things like awesome i've been
[Music]
it's like an asian person being like hey
we're both asian
is that better than being from salt lake
city like this doofus
[Music]
how
um caleb what did you uh what did you do
in utah in salt lake city
um what did i do i
just hung out i was working at a tech
company back then and uh yeah i didn't
do much i left utah because i don't do
any of the utah things i'm not mormon i
don't see
ski is the snow when i was younger
[Music]
interesting um you uh used to work in
tech in salt lake city which is like
reading the book of mormon
into a tape recorder
often not very often
i actually was in salt lake city this
weekend this morning actually played a
little arena called the maverick center
maybe you heard over there
mormons
squeeze them all in there yell at them
tell them joseph smith's the pedophile
did you uh do you guys have any morbid
jokes or they had a bunch of mormon jets
but they're mormon more like booker
storming the capital you guys are all
trump supporters
uh but uh yeah so where
where do you live in austin
northwest austin
okay i don't know anything about there
domain
uh
caleb what where do you like to hang out
in austin what do you like to do here i
like to hang out here 6th street creek
it's a good time
this is like here at my house
zilker
[Music]
if we could go to the temple let's go
back to salt lake city we'll go to town
square is there anything right here
there's [ __ ]
yeah
i'm not sure about the mormon presence
in austin
that's good there's got to be someone
we like to keep them
scared
uh so do you like to you like to go to
the buddhist temple you pay respects to
your cambodian heritage
[Music]
uh
oh yes the thailand temples we all know
so much about them
[Music]
just praying for you know
all that
reincarnation right everybody comes up
and comes back as like a caterpillar
[Music]
something
well you're as a white man
well that was our time we uh only had a
couple minutes with you guys but uh i
like to think that you guys have a lot a
lot left to talk about at barton springs
yeah so go ahead
keep an eye
and stop at bucky's if you have to that
was sammy and caleb ogden
uh that was those are the dates for
tonight what do you think about the
problem
i think there's potential there's a lot
of potentials tonight
we even had some
lesbians
which is great because it's pride week
yeah um anything you want to promote
um so i do post a show in houston called
look but don't touch comedy and
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh you can find rachel on instagram
and twitter
yeah princess by the priest rachel
mcmillan and yeah thanks for having me
give it up for rachel
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one second
[Music]
[Music]
i wait till they get up and walk
[Music]
big